To start our problem, we want to multiply the numerator and denominator by the
conjugate of this denominator. The conjugate of root 2 plus root 5, is root 2
minus root 5. We distribute this 6 to each of these terms to get 6 root 2 minus
6 root 5. Next, we use our difference of squares factoring pattern, to do a
squared minus b squared. We square root 2 to get 2 and we square root 5 to get
5. Next we subtract inner denominator to get a denominator of negative 3, and
here's where we want to be careful. When we simplify we can divide negative 3
into this term and into this term, 6 divided by negative 3 is negative 2, and
negative 6 divided by negative 3 is positive 2. This is how we get our answer
of negative 2 root 2, plus 2 root 5. Another way the think about it is to
factor a negative 3 from each of these terms. If we factor a negative 3 from
this first term, we'll be left with negative 2 times root 2. And we factor a
negative 3 from this term we'll be left with 2 root 5. We can check this really
quickly by distributing this negative 3 to each of these terms. We'll wind up
with our numerator from before. Now that we have a common factor of negative 3
in the numerator and in the denominator we can simplify. These reduce to 1
which leaves us with just our numerator, negative 2 root 2 plus 2 root 5. And
now there are a couple of ways to write this answer. You could have factored a
negative 2 out to get this answer or you could have factored a positive 2 out.
Either of these is correct. Nice algebraic thinking if you got any of these
answers.